Yeah,
I do agree with that.
Uh,
we'll leave.
The government should be open.
Uh,
I think the worst example was when the
vice president said he wasn't as good as
submit to the scrutiny of Congress when
they asked them for a documents.
And then outrageously he said that he
was not going to provide them cause he
wasn't a member of the executive branch.
And I sat the Ysl well,
what is he a farmer?
My point is that when it comes to
national security,
when it comes to just simple
information,
I'll give you an example.
Uh,
I got into a little trouble when I said
at one of the debates that,
uh,
on Ufos aliens,
I don't believe in him,
but one of the problems that have been
compounded about propagating this myth
that aliens exist in Roswell,
New Mexico was because the government
has not provided full disclosure of
incidents that happened years ago about
possible landings in Roswell,
New Mexico.
And if they just released all the
information,
uh,
they wouldn't have had this problem.
Yeah,
I do believe in general,
government is very secretive.
It's very bureaucratic in many cases.
It turns people off.
It's very impersonal.
And one of the,
one of the objectives I would have is to
make the government more,
more friendly to people,
more responsive to people.
I would do that by leading by example.
I would,
uh,
look at everything that needed to be
declassified,
national security,
a domestic,
and I would say this is the first step
we're going to do.
Uh,
secondly,
I would also say to the American people,
uh,
I'm going to give you access to your
president.
I think the president is assemble a of
American government and leadership.
What I would do is I'd submit to
unfettered town meetings with the
American people.
I'd have office hours where ordinary
people could come to see me as long as
it were five minutes and they didn't
carry a weapon.
Actually,
I've done that as governor.
I would,
uh,
make the White House more part of the
American family,
make it more accessible.
Uh,
obviously a president has to worry about
security,
but I would spend a night in people's
homes just trying to explain that
government can be on the side of the
American people.
One of our big problems has been that
the American people think that
government is simply,
is not on their side.
That government is there to block
progress at government is there to make
things more difficult,
more bureaucratic.
A lot of it is the tone of leadership
that a president would break.
Okay.